The second one might have been tricky but they both equal negative 1. We want to
remember that the negative sign is really a negative 1 being multiplied by this
expression. We know x plus 3 divided by x plus 3 equals 1. So now we can
simplify our fraction. This just leaves us with negative 1. For our second
rational expression, we can think of a 1 being outside of the expression a plus
4. For the denominator, we're going to factor out a negative 1. Leaving us with
negative 1 a plus 4. If we were to distribute this negative 1 back inside the
parenthesis we'd get our original denominator. We know this step is correct. We
can simplify the a plus 4s since they equal 1leaving us with 1 times 1 in the
numerator and negative 1 times 1 in the denominator. This just simplifies to
negative 1. You might have spotted this first one easily. Great work if you. If
you did. It's okay if this one gave you trouble.